[Music]
hello everyone and welcome
my name is
and I lead the product management team
for dataplex
today I'm super excited to talk to you
about existing and new capabilities in
dataplex that'll help you govern your
data at scale
organizations around the world are
trying to be more data driven but what
does it mean to be more data driven
data is easily discoverable and
available to different teams in the
tools of their choice
individuals who need access to data can
get it easily but in a way that is
secure and compliant with your
organization's policies
and teams can rely on data and trust it
to drive meaningful actionable business
outcomes
now that sounds great
but why do organizations struggle to
realize this picture
in a study done by Accenture they found
that two-thirds of a company's data goes
unused for Analytics
furthermore in a recent five trans
survey ninety percent of the teens said
that unreliable data sources slow down
their work
Gartner predicts that through 2025 80
percent of the organizations seeking to
scale digital businesses will fail if
they do not take a modern approach to
data and analytics governance
now with data being becoming more and
more distributed and the needs on that
data are growing having a comprehensive
governance solution has become Paramount
for organizations looking to be more
data driven
and that is why we launch dataplex
earlier this year to provide customers a
unified data fabric that can help them
manage and govern their distributed data
at scale
since launch we have unified data
catalog with dataplex to provide you
robust capabilities around metadata
management
centralized security and governance and
intelligent data management
across your entire Enterprise landscape
in dataplex we are leveraging metadata
as a foundation to provide you
comprehensive governance capabilities
with the flexibility to self-serve the
capabilities that are relevant to your
needs
the core principles for dataplex are
around enabling you to apply governance
based on your business context and
business logic
give you the ability to Define your
governance rules based on business
context and data attributes that map to
the understanding of your data rather
than the physical storage of data
and finally give you a unified
governance platform that is open and
extensible so you can enable end-to-end
data governance across your entire data
landscape
and as a result of that you are able to
enable a data mesh architecture within
your organization that maps to your
business structure and enables
autonomous ownership of data with
centralized governance
we have a number of customers across
multiple industry verticals using
dataplex today to govern the data at
scale and make trusted data available to
drive business outcomes
when we think of governance we think of
enabling 3K key pillars for you
enabling you to discover data with
business context providing you the tools
to centrally secure and manage your data
and providing you capabilities that will
enable you to build trust in your data
now let's take a look at each one of
these in a little more detail
for discovering data with business
context you can centrally manage all
your metadata in a data catalog in
dataplex
once your data is cataloged you can now
enrich that data with relevant business
context to drive consistent
understanding of your data across your
organization
and then you can use a unified interface
to search discover
explore and share data within your
organization
dataplex already catalogs metadata from
a number of gcp sources into the central
data catalog
but we are now extending that support to
databases specifically Cloud SQL
bigtable and spanner and adding support
to catalog looker metadata
with this you have a comprehensive view
of your data from a single unified
catalog with the ability to easily
search discover
and understand your data across your
Enterprise
but oftentimes cataloging metadata is
not enough you want to enrich this data
with relevant business context
dataplex provides you the flexibility to
use stack templates to augment your
technical metadata with business
contacts
and today we are further enhancing the
business enrichment capabilities Within
dataplex by introducing two new
capabilities a business glossary that
will enable your data stewards and
subject matter experts to Define
standardized business terms and
taxonomies that can then be applied to
your data by all the data teams within
your organization
and Rich Text documentation that can
provide a way for your teams to create a
shared understanding of your data by
crowdsourcing and collaborating on Rich
business contexts and storing that right
within the catalog as part of the
metadata of a given entry instead of in
wikis and personal nodes across your
organization
together these features along with
existing features such as stack
templates help you create a shared and
common understanding of your data within
your organization and enable your teams
to effectively use share and collaborate
over data
in addition to Discovery and enrichment
dataplex also provides a data
exploration workbench
this workbench gives your data consumers
one-click access to spark SQL and
notebooks with the ability to save their
work share their work and collaborate
across teams
as well as operationalize their work
with one-click scheduling built right
into the workbench
it also gives your data admins the
ability to pre-configure and Define the
environments for different teams and use
cases
your data admins can govern access to
these environments track usage and
attribute consumption per user or team
across your organization
today this feature is available in
preview and it will be generally
available soon
now let's move to the next pillar around
centrally securing and managing your
data
with dataplex you can secure access to
your data using business contacts
instead of uh instead of terminology
that Maps your underlying infrastructure
you can provide secure access to your
data
across your organization in a way where
you're enabling distributed ownership of
the data while still having centralized
governance so let's take a closer look
in dataplex you can logically organize
your data by defining data domains and
sub-domains and then map your Access
Control policies at the Domain level
across distributed data
dataplex will then take these policies
and map to the underlying physical
resources
propagate them at scale
to data that is stored in different
storage products
as well as across different gcp projects
you can easily designate data owners
producers and admins and have teams
self-manage their data while still
having the ability to Monitor and audit
all actions centrally as well as apply
certain governance policies across all
your data domains
in addition to defining policies at the
Domain level
we are now introducing the ability to
create attributes and Define your
business taxonomy within the dataplex
attributes tool and then Define your
governance policies based on these
attributes
as an example you can easily Define
different data classes like pii data map
the attributes that are considered pii
within your organization and Define
policies associated with that
we are starting with Access Control
policies which dataplex will then map to
the tables and columns and apply them at
scale to data in GCS and bigquery we
have bigquery tables and Big Lake tables
this feature will be available in
preview in the in the early part of 2023
in addition to policy propagation we're
also enhancing our existing GCS data
Discovery capability by now adding
support to create big lake and object
tables at scale
so what does that actually mean
instead of creating bigquery connections
and big league tables one table at a
time you can simply Point your GCS
buckets where your analytics data
resides to dataplex and dataplex will
automatically set up the connections
create both big league tables for
structured data and object tables for
unstructured data and keep this data and
metadata in sync as new data arrives
dataplex will also make this available
as part of the data catalog so that this
data is easily discoverable and
accessible to your teams
and finally let's look at how dataplex
can help you build trust in your data by
getting that 360 View and understanding
of your data improving data reliability
and enabling you to have better data
obserability
so the First new capability that will
help you build better trust in your data
is automatic data profiling and data
quality
with automatic data profiling you can
profile your data and have that profile
be available alongside your metadata
you can then use that profile to Auto
generate data quality rules
and run them at scale on a fully managed
serverless platform
you can check for things like
completeness accuracy validity and
freshness
as well as add your own custom rules for
custom checks that you want to enable on
your data
you can track the your data quality
metrics at a granular level
at a specific table level within
dataplex or within bigquery
to ensure that the data that you're
using meets your data Quality Bar
but you can also monitor the overall
health of your data with built-in
dashboards and reports that will be
available Within dataplex
and finally in addition to monitoring
your data quality you can also set up
built-in actions to quarantine data that
does not meet your data quality
thresholds
so for that we are announcing the
general availability of lineage which
will be available in early part of 2023.
our goal is to provide you end-to-end
data lineage with automatic processing
of lineage for gcp sources and
extensibility to third-party sources
lineage is available alongside the rest
of the metadata and dataplex so you can
trace the origins of your data to its
upstream and downstream relationships
and use it to understand your data
better
identify data issues and use lineage as
a foundation to apply your governance
and compliance policies
we are starting with bigquery which is
the lineage for which is currently in
preview and will be available uh in
general availability in q1 of 2023
and we are also extending that support
to composer and data Fusion so you can
track your lineage across your data
integration and data movement pipelines
in addition to your analytics store
and in addition to that we are also
making our lineage apis available so you
can embed them in your own custom tools
and ingest lineage into dataplex
and that's all I have for you today I
went through many different capabilities
that will be available to you in the
coming months in each one of these three
pillars to really help you discover your
data with business context
centrally secure and manage your data
and build trust in your data so that you
can govern your data at scale
to learn more please visit these
additional resources as well as visit
our product page listed at the bottom
and thank you for your time today and I
hope you have a great rest of next 22.
[Music]